just last night a man was shot during a
robbery at a store parking lot and then
of course you'll remember there were
multiple violent attacks and parking
structures on new year's eve so the
question is how can you protect yourself
if you're in that same situation just
kind of walking to and from your car
bianca holmen live this morning with
some answers bianca good morning to you
yeah walking to and from our car trying
to find our keys or looking down at our
phone we do it so often that it's second
nature but we spoke with self-defense
experts and they say anytime you're in
transit you could become a target so we
checked in with a krav mcgraw expert
donovan britt he's with las vegas krav
maga and he says that if you're being
robbed don't try to fight for your
things your life is worth more than
those items get away seek help call
police he also says many people carry
things like pepper spray blades or even
a handgun but those aren't foolproof
protection
anything they use as a weapon whether
it's your empty hands or whether it's a
pencil or whether it's a firearm if
you're not training it's useless to you
and i know a lot of people carry weapons
i you know i'm not anti hang on at all
in fact i'm a gun owner but you must
train with these weapons you must train
in a way that is stress related so that
you can perform those motions under
stress
brett also explains that if you're being
attacked and someone is trying to take
you and not your items your response has
to be explosive so thumbs to the eyes
kicking to the groin or even punches to
the head and ears and of course there
must be training like he's talked about
there's several self-defense programs
and facilities around the valley so
they're always doing these seminars to
help you protect yourself in those types
of incidents and situations that could
happen at random reporting live bianca
holmen live local now